so here we are at camp one at just under
20,000 feet and we're actually camp now
on the khumbu glacier and we're in the
Western combe or Valley we're surrounded
by the three peaks Everest load seat
oopsy it's kind of a dead-ended valley
and this massive movement of ice is now
slowly moving down being pulled by
gravity and as it goes down over this
cliff down below us it creates the
Khumbu Icefall about 5am here we're
headed up to the Icefall stopped right
here below what we call the popcorn a
lot of Big Sur acts ice blocks that can
move this is the last place we can
really stop safely we're up to the
popcorn we're probably close to 19,000
feet here this ice fall it's a glacier
and it's a living moving thing it never
stopped it's actually flowing slowly
three or four feet per day over
difficult and steep bedrock and that's
what creates these crevasses and that's
what creates this chaos of ice blocks
called Cyrax and it's constantly moving
and that's why we want to move through
the ice ball very very quickly we're at
the top of the football field here just
took a quick break but some fairly large
sir acts up above once we're through
that we're home free up on top and into
camp one
so right ahead at the end of the valley
here we can see the peak load seat and
this is where the glacier begins you can
see a series of frozen waves as the
glacier now is slowly moving down the
valley and you can see the striations or
the layers of annual snowfall in the
sections of the racks that we can see
exposed we're going to spend one night
here at Camp one and tomorrow we're
going to get up early move to camp two
and hopefully spent two or three nights
there and it's really great to be out of
base camp that's for sure